all right hey everybody i'm here it's
the first night of the republican
national convention
and we're all going to watch together i
don't know if we're going to have
a cringe stream i don't know if we're go
i just don't know what we're going to
have
what i heard is that donald trump has
already spoken like
two or three times today it just seems
that he's a little bit overexposed and
completely desperate for attention as
always
um but it is starting at the bottom of
the hour there's a couple
different um there's a bunch of
different clips that i saw
from people earlier like for example
this is one guy i mean
it's off the rails instantly we love
both mother and child
but where joe biden is hiding in the
dark waiting to take the lives of our
unborn babies so that sort of gives you
a sense of what's going on let me look
at some of the other videos that
aaron posted who's covering all of this
stuff very powerfully
um okay look check this out
be very careful this is going to be
and i really believe this this is the
most important
election in the history of our country
don't let them take it away from i agree
with that
don't let them take it away north
carolina we love you that's why i'm here
thank you very much
very special people thank you god bless
you all thank you
okay so just everything about it is
weird
and along the beautiful those beautiful
war fields that we have they're coming
from everywhere sir i've never seen
anything like it
but if other states are like tennessee
you're going to win this election
also the buzzing throughout the entire
thing is really weird
nobody's done more for the
african-american community
no president has done as much as anybody
since i mean since and i say it since
abraham lincoln it's true weird then he
says there's going to be 300 supreme
court justices of course there's only
nine
republicans did not make it easy let's
say but you know if you have enough time
there's not much anybody can do about it
we ended up with 142
judges and then we've added many many
and we're going to end up with 302 great
supreme court justices that'll be quite
a supreme court and then the delusions
continue
more we've accomplished more
during the first three and a half years
of this administration
than any president in the history of our
country
and what's funny about that and i'm
going to have a whole segment about it
tomorrow
is that if they've done more than any
president
why is their platform remaining
unchanged for the next four years
like if you in other words if you put
together a platform in 2016
and you accomplish more than anybody and
then in 2020 you go we're not changing
the platform the platform is the same
did you really accomplish anything it
doesn't strike me
uh that uh that that you did so we're
going to have
a lot of wild wild times here super
chats are coming in
wildly um people sending
twitch messages like for example remy's
alter ego
subscribed for two months and says
congrats on your pog
champs victory i did finally win a match
earlier today
um omega jrs and young freud
mitsuo philip uranus
i do them separately in order to protect
myself has grabbed a subscription
reglitch a lot of different people
um let's see we'll look at a few
messages
chakuseki says david could you give a
shout out to my boy big smoke up spencer
the valley
sure um he also says plasma for all
plasma all around cameron titus is
craziest scheduled speaker for the rnc
2020
well let's just look at today i don't
know about the entire thing today we're
gonna hear from tim scott
let's go one by one tim scott steve
scalise okay scalise is crazier than
scott
matt gates gates is crazier than scalise
jim jordan that's tough i mean i think
jordan and gates are equally bonkers
nikki haley's less crazy than them ronna
mcdaniels less crazy than them vernon
jones is less crazy
amy johnson guilfoyle harp charlie kirk
i think charlie kirk is is just not that
bright i don't think he's crazy
kim klaischik mark and patricia
mccloskey are the saint louis couple
with the guns sean parnell don jr
herschel walker
i think that gates and jim jordan for
we'll take it day by day
i think gates and jordan today are the
craziest
people um okay
unknown prodigy says i can't tell you
how disappointed i am in pog champs game
two you had 20
000 different ways to win and choked and
then choked again come on david i won
the match that's what matters three
points
up on the board gregory shavers jr says
i'm glad you're here with us to watch
the cringe donna williams a big thank
you for covering this i couldn't watch
it otherwise
solar says it's going to be a political
circus
chris says love the content cameron
titus says current oh that we just did
that
brian holliday says upper or downer
trump i don't know that we're gonna see
trump tonight i think you know trump was
earlier
and he's gonna be speaking a little bit
each day but his big speech is thursday
uh philip says david over 1500 people
were here hanging out for the last 45
minutes cracking jokes and more we're
disappointed you're late but glad you're
here
uh okay so i'm not late and there
weren't 1500 people here
um for 45 minutes but 15 minutes ago
there were certainly fifteen hundred
people let's be accurate philip please
and thank you for your support
bay photo says sensing trump will try to
announce a vaccine at the rnc
1147 cloud says mr pogchamp game will
you be posting them on youtube i didn't
even record
i wasn't even streaming for today's so
probably not
freedomcleaner asks do i think i could
beat trump in chess
that no one knows more strategy than him
i have no idea if he's any good
sabres man asks if i'm ready for this
horror show
i'm very much ready absolutely okay we
have a hype train
out of the station on twitch purdy 1999
has subscribed sonya lang
has sent a cheer and there's a lot of
extremely
extremely exciting things going on
deway sun has subscribed on
youtube we will be keeping an eye on
trump's twitter
to see what he posts
uh an hour ago he posted about joe biden
joe biden says he would lock down the
country again that's crazy we're having
record job growth and a booming stock
market but joe would end it all and
close it all down ridiculous
yeah so he really has no idea sort of
like how to deal with a pandemic
which is not news to us i think we
certainly knew that
um let me say thank you to
ellen sands cody greer
and michael brennan who are new members
one two and three today
hey this is just really really funny i
think some of you will appreciate this
so for two weeks i've been promoting
that on august 23rd which is yesterday
it's the 15th anniversary of the david
pakman show in some form
you know in some way shape or form and
we're going to have this
big membership special on august 23rd
get on our mailing list i'll let you
know about it
yesterday shows up we send out this
beautiful membership special people are
loving it
um people are signing up and then just
for kicks
i was like something is feeling weird
about august 23rd was that really the
date
i check a calendar and august 23rd 2005
was a tuesday
our show used to be wednesdays only it
wasn't even the date
so it was actually august 17th we got
the date wrong of our own 15th
anniversary
but it doesn't matter we're still
running the membership special and the
coupon code is
15 year one five year so
you can go to joinpakman.com the coupon
code above my head is good
the coupon code 15 year is great one
five year okay and i will we have a goal
of 25 members as you can see
and i will be thanking everybody or at
least doing my best
to do so which is very exciting but it's
a it's it's a coupon code
they wouldn't allow a coupon code like
this in a lot of states where you can
marry your cousin
you can do that this coupon code would
be not allowed
you understand okay good um
let's see other messages coming in
during the propaganda video
oh people are asking where things are
from the standpoint of subscribers on
youtube
we're at 963 000. we're only 20 from a
964
000. so i would love to hit 9.65
tonight that's my goal but things are
going
well and when i say they're going well
they're really going well it's not like
when trump says we're doing great on the
virus things are actually going well
uh in the fight for one million
mitsuo has gifted 10 subscriptions
dub fotek has subscribed mini man i
wonder if that's michael bloomberg
mini man has subscribed
cerseus chorus has also subscribed
let's see this insane video that's
playing here now
we all know that it is easy to criticize
we all know that it is easy to criticize
it takes a true leader to solve problems
[Music]
covert 19 while others critically
imagine
running on doing a good job on covet if
you're trump swift action
saved lives and as leading democrats
want to keep businesses closed down
our president is leading the way for a
full economic recovery
i'm like already almost done like i
don't know that i'm gonna make it
through the next 10 minutes never mind
four nights of this it's crazy
um philip says i watched the 730 minute
pre-show grow to 2000 when you started
now you're at 5.5 000. yeah fuzzy
numbers but love is still there
beautiful tristan michelle says do you
have the rnc bingo card ready
you know i was i i was so busy today i
was not able to get it ready but i'm
gonna try to get it ready for tomorrow
johnny minogue says good thing you got
your smoke detectors fixed in advance of
this fish market dumpster fire
on today's bonus show i explained why
firefighters were at my house at 4 30 in
the morning over the weekend
that's on today's bonus show okay
it is a hell of a story hell of a story
you can't even imagine
um nicholas smith says why do americans
tend to vote out of fear
instead of voting for the best candidate
despite the party
i.e third party for me voting third
party is the only moral choice well
because we have first passed the post
voting in the u.s and so voting third
party
can end up playing spoiler let's see
what's going on now
the video is not even like the frame
rate is all messed up
let us pray oh my god and pray
we must as grateful citizens of a
country
i'm going to focus i just can't do the
total propaganda so we're not going to
do the prayer once we get to the
speeches i i will get to it
fooze coach asks do twitch subs get the
bonus show
no unfortunately not uh you got to be a
member on my website or
on patreon or patreon as i call it
um okay we have achieved a level five
hype train
beautiful beautiful unknown prodigy asks
does it upset you that the rnc gets more
views than the dnc because of the
entertainment value not really
not really but i did expect that the rnc
streams would do better than the dnc
streams and i think we topped out on
youtube
at 8 500 at the peak of the dnc
and we're already at 7 400 on youtube
and like
no one's even spoken yet so it is you
know i understand the train wreck
aspect of it no bingo today
bernie sanders is it through the coveted
19 death count no no no
you know br that user just doesn't know
how to send an interesting super chat
uh mike michael hunt says will you be
donating
plasma if you get covered i may
i may simp king says what would happen
if trump nominated
melania as vp probably nothing trump
could shoot people on
fifth avenue and people wouldn't even uh
wouldn't even be bothered
jenna ayers says please pause don't mute
we miss all his lies
barry crocker says run trump transcript
through a russian translator
philip naumann says dp is the mystery
science theater 2000 of politics that's
interesting
alex kepcke says do you think the rnc
will get you to vote red
listen i'm going to put out a statement
right now if anybody watching
is convinced to vote trump based on the
rnc
i want to hear from you here's charlie
blork it is an honor to be with you
tonight
my name is charlie kirk i run the
largest pro american student
organization in the country
turning point usa fighting for the
future of our republic
speaking to you in my personal capacity
tonight as a 26 year old
i see the angst of young people as well
as the challenges
facing new parents i am here tonight to
tell you
to warn you that this election is a
decision between preserving
why isn't the video i hope people
understand the production value of this
is a disaster it's not on my end it's
all
jittery and both by the way how is
charlie kirk's head so big but face so
small it's unusual
faceless corporations and to
self-serving lobbyists
they did it to preserve their own power
and enrich themselves
all while rigging the system to hold
down the good decent middle class
patriots
striving to build a family and pursue a
decent life
all of this changed dramatically in 2015
when a billionaire named donald trump
put his own life of luxury on the line
from that moment he came down that
famous escalator
he started a movement to reclaim our
government
from the rotten cartel of insiders that
have been destroying
our country now just so people know like
there's no way to fact check that
i don't know that he said anything
that's true other than maybe his name
and in fact that i would want to see a
license for
we're just watching it together like you
can't possibly fact check a hundred
or a thousand lies our way of life our
neighborhoods
schools churches and values
president trump was elected to defend
the american
way of life the american way of life
means you follow the law you work hard
you honor god you raise your kids with
strong values
and you work to create a civil society
the american way of life means you speak
your mind
without retribution without being kicked
off social media by a self-righteous
censor
in silicon valley it means you can
freely practice your religion
and that church is more essential than a
casino
right and it means that we judge people
on their actions
not on their immutable characteristics
the american way of life is being
dismantled by a group of bitter
deceitful vengeful activists who have
never built
anything in their lives they have us
locking up pastors
while releasing violent criminals from
prison we are kicking doctors off of
social media
yet promoting chinese state-funded
propaganda on major
tech platforms oh my god this election
is the most critical since 1860
when a man named lincoln was elected to
preserve the union
from disintegration this is crazy this
election is not just the most important
of
our lifetime it is the most important
since the preservation of the republic
in 1865. by reelecting trump we will
ensure that our kids are raised
to love our country and respect its
founding fathers
not taught to hate or be ashamed of them
we will build monuments to heroes not
burn down our cities
we'll be a country that rises the higher
heights that dreams big
thinks big and achieves the impossible a
country that values our remarkable
journey the complexities of our past
but clearly communicates to the next
generation
that we have to be grateful not
angry that we live in the united states
we will be a country that makes it
easier to have many children
live quiet and peaceable lives and
worship your god
without a tyrant getting in the way
we will be a country that has its best
100 years ahead
we will build a future where america
remains the greatest country
ever to exist in the history of the
world all of that
is within our grasp if we secure four
more
civilizations for the defender of
western civilization
our champion my friend the 45th
president of the united states
president i'm just going to switch
stream real quick
this is the official stream that was the
trump stream this is the rnc
stream that was literally crazy i mean
you would have to suspend
all belief of anything in order to
um believe that we're gonna skip this
one where i'm gonna really hit the
highlights and get the big names
um the super chats are just flying
in james montalbano says the bigger the
lie the more they believe yeah that's
very much true
kyle hopper says thank you for being
here dave video seminite plasman
david plosman i like that james dewine
says trump pardoned war criminals what
the [ __ ] is this nonsense oh my god
that's super aggressive um
mazzy z says achieve the impossible okay
looking at you covet 19
how can we afford to have many children
when our costs are so high
i'll do the best i can to keep up with
super chats they're just going in
fast and furious i do feel like i've
lost two iq points so far and we're only
11 minutes in scott hack says how much
do i have to drink to tolerate this
uh that's a great that's a great
question
playable tengu says charlie kirk is
similar to pinocchio every time he tells
a lie his head grows and his face
shrinks yeah it was very strange facial
structure
if he has marfan syndrome or something i
completely i'm not making fun of him in
any way and i want to make sure we're
not
um you know i mean it's just he has a
distinctive look is all i mean i
i want to be real careful steve parney
says david a survey says 70
of republicans are happy with the
economy how many people actually
identify as republican that's a fair
question
this is going to be good i know it says
david thanks for stomaching all of this
crap for us i'll only be able to bear it
in parts here and there
that i understand that i understand and
what's insane is again
dramatically more interest in these
streams than for the dnc we've already
got
we're about to breach uh 9 500 on
youtube
and we never got that at any point
during the dnc
i don't think it's because my audience
plans to vote for this nonsense
i think it's because you you're looking
at it the way you look at
a car accident on the highway you know
uh
that's that's everyone loves a mess
exactly i think that's exactly right
um okay trevor showman says i think
trump really feels he creates a new
thing with plasma whereas the rest of
the world has been using
plasma in his mind he really did invent
maybe that's the case maybe that's the
case
sabres man says sadly while we see this
as crazy trump is
see it and think it's genius
interesting um not gonna fall for this
one just so people you know
not gonna fall for that one not
happening thanks to optical monk for
subscribing
at tier one let's do some new member
thank yous because they are rolling in
davis patterson is new member number
four
clark miyazaki is number five
susan johnson den is number six ivan
delgado number seven
anthony cifelli is number eight and
antonia duthit
is number nine at joinpackman.com
the website is under a lot of pressure
you guys are putting a lot of pressure
on the website but so far
it is holding up scheduled to speak
today matt gates
jim shorts jordan rona mcdaniel
we already heard from charlie kirk this
is an education
activist and i think that the consensus
from the dnc was not to cover
what we might call the minor streams of
the minor speeches rather
so we are going to be focusing in on the
uh the major speeches
and oh this looks pre-produced to be
perfectly frank because that
didn't the speakers switch a little too
quickly do you guys want to hear from
tanya winerice a small business owner
yes no maybe so
no sure let's check in on it corporation
our success is not measured by
stockholders
but by our neighbors the people we see
at church
and at jiu jitsu school with our son oh
my god
mountain mud espresso is the american
story
a story not just for entrepreneurs but
for millions of hard-working
men and women who are building their
american dream every day
a few months ago like so many businesses
we got the crushing news
i got a better stream guys i was scared
i thought of our 50 employees the
mountain mud family
and when i thought of their jobs i
thought of their rent being due
their kids so if we don't watch on the
official one
we won't see the names of trump's donors
on the bottom of the screen
i think i would trade that for better
better video his words ran clear
keep on working it will be okay
i had faith and let me tell you you have
to have faith when your husband is a
marine
and a police officer who was shot at on
the job
and when you run a business a little
faith goes a long way
faith in jesus and faith in america
all right so i'm i'm gonna have to nope
right out of there that's
cringy and uh you know soon we'll have
um other speakers that we're gonna pay
very very close attention to things are
happening over on twitch
rhapsodies on graz with a nine month
prime membership says i'm assuming trump
will be reelected in order to prepare
for the worst
i'll still vote biden though david igaro
says i have been subscribed since august
but forgot my password
anyway thank you for being one of the
only rational progressives thank you
also thanks to loot hobbit and lawson129
for the subscription
very much appreciate that we have uh
breached
1 000 viewers over on twitch which is
beautiful
let's see if we can get to 10k on
youtube though we're closing
in nicholas silva says thank you david
sir your assessments on the right and
the rnc are some of the best ever sir
your work is amazing sir
love from haverhill massachusetts joseph
ernst says kirk's agenda
one scare suburban white women two
scare old business investors three scare
the elderly by talking about communist
china cartels and activists essentially
yeah that was that was the strategy
rebecca phillips has anyone noticed the
rnc logo now has a crown
uh i did not see that
and here is matt gates okay this one
we're going to listen to buckle up
congressman matt gates i'm speaking to
you from an auditorium
emptier than joe biden's daily schedule
but we are a nation of full hearts and
clear minds
we see the choice clearly strength or
weakness
energy or confusion success or failure
president trump is the first president
since reagan not to start a new war
biden has foolishly cheerled decades of
war without winning
without end president trump knows we are
strongest when we fight hardest
not in distant deserts but for our
fellow americans
we must fight to save america now or we
may lose her forever
joe biden might not even notice settle
for biden
that's the hashtag promoted by aoc and
the socialists
the woketopians will settle for biden
because they will make him an extra in a
movie
written produced and directed by others
it's a horror film really
they'll disarm you empty the prisons
lock you in your home
and invite ms-13 to live next door and
the police aren't coming when you call
this is almost like a live willy horton
ad being defunded
disbanded blaming our best and
allowing society's worst that's the
story they write in hollywood
that's if the lights even stay on in
california anymore
a state that cannot keep power running
for its own people
should not send its junior senator to be
vice president
they used to write only in fiction but
nightmares are becoming real
cops killed children shot at the
democrat convention they say
if you vote against trump it will all
stop
appeasement is never a winning strategy
no we won't settle
for violence in our neighborhoods or at
our border we won't settle for decades
of bad decisions by basement dwelling
joe biden
we settle a continent we know that the
frontier the horizon
even the stars belong to us donald trump
like all builders
is a visionary the stars belong to us
even more powerful than the brick and
mortar that holds it together
first comes the mind then the making
first comes the vision
then the work washington lincoln and
jefferson are immortal
precisely because of the pull they have
on our imagination
this guy actually seems out of his mind
i've never seen him speak at length
the dangerous left need america to be
weaker to accomplish their goal of
replacing her
we know that to make america great again
we must first make something
of ourselves so the four years wasn't
enough to make it great okay
great grandfather was a railroad man as
a florida man i watch our rockets
routinely send
the brightest beyond the heavens with
our flag and our hope
america is the greatest country that has
ever existed
don't let any celebrity athlete or
politician tell you otherwise
president trump sometimes raises his
voice and a ruckus
he knows that's what it takes to raise
an army of patriots
who love america and will protect her
we must win this election if we cherish
our country as much as we should
for there is no place to run no refuge
for freedom should we fail
america is not just an idea or a
constitution
it is our home we must protect our home
with unbreakable made in america
strength
strength i see every day in president
donald trump
thank you absolutely and completely
delusional i i if that's what we're in
for four days of
i'll probably get through the next 30
minutes and have to bail guys
unfortunately i mean i don't that that
is it it is like uh
it's pond scum it's pond scum and the
craziest thing
is somewhere between 60 and 68 million
people are going to see this and go
that's what i'm voting for
that's the really scary thing um super
chats are just exploding we've never
seen anything
like it uh g g
plants as fox news isn't even running
this that that's interesting if true
rebecca phillips says where is the my
pillow guy in diamond and silk that's a
fair question
life quinoa pachito
lil quinoa pachito says smash the like
button my fellow woktopians yeah if
you're a woktopian in the audience
please destroy that subscribe button
la laker says two main speeches and it's
already insane yeah i mean
it's it we when we say we have a mental
health crisis in this country
i'm not making fun of anyone or joking i
mean there are literal crazy people
speaking at the rnc
these are folks where if you went to a
therapist and said here's what i believe
you would be put into treatment right
they would say we should probably go up
to twice a week
yeah wow it's unbelievable what we are
seeing here
thanks to hack fewee for the twitch
subscription
as well as breezy for the support
puntu babu deeper shades of house
a lot of people checking in and
supporting over on twitch which i love
um okay
trevor shorman says picture that speech
with the starship troopers news music
and commentaries
yeah it's weaponized propaganda it's
unbelievable
jessica doyle says no don't bail i'm
trying to get our unseed bingo almost
got it on ready i don't think i can
survive this without your sane person
commentary
okay i'm gonna try to stick it out for
as long as i can
joseph ernst says david seriously our
media would be like dictators goon
dictator goon spread propaganda for
military junta
pookie new jack city says the scary
thing is the two choices for president
here is who is this i have no idea who
this is
is this someone we want to listen to
kick off this historic
convention as we speak this is ronald
mcdonald i had no idea what she looked
like first to those facing terrible
fires in california
recovering from storms in iowa and
preparing for hurricanes
in louisiana and the gulf coast
democrats started their convention last
week with eva longoria
a famous hollywood actress who played a
housewife on tv
okay well i'm actually a real housewife
and a mom from isn't she a romney like
isn't she a wealthy
super wealthy romney or something who
happens to be the only
only the second woman in 164 years to
run
the republican party and unlike joe
biden
president trump didn't choose me because
i'm a woman
he chose me because i was the best
person
for the job okay four years ago
president trump started a movement
unlike any other and over the next four
days we will hear from a few of the
millions of
hard-working everyday americans who have
benefited
from his leadership if you watched the
dnc
last week you probably noticed that
democrats spent a lot of time
talking about how much they despise our
president
well yeah but we heard very little about
their actual
policies that's not true policies that
would have been unthinkable
a decade ago policies like banning
fossil fuels
well yeah the country has become more
liberal so it makes sense that over time
i mean
biden's climate policies to the left of
hillary's which was to the left of
obama's like that makes sense the
country has moved left bound to the fact
that they think
he's a nice guy well let me tell you
raising taxes on 82 percent of americans
is not nice so joe biden has made it
clear
taxes would not go up on people making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year
policies that force jobs to flee our
country
or allow abortion up until the point of
birth
are not nice the truth is
there's only one person who has
empathized with everyday americans
and actually been fighting for them over
the past four years
all right so her critique is that dnc
was not nice the policies are
not nice that's the critique here okay
wow um rebecca phillips says she was the
last one left willing to do the job yeah
kyle downey says matt gates makes me sad
to be a floridian
um hemi lifestyle says love you david
big fan but not a stalker type fan i
appreciate that thank you
john cato says i'm in therapy twice a
month with adhd bipolar asperger's and
oppositional defiant disorder and i'm
nowhere close to this level of crazy
good lord
uh that that probably is the top super
chat of the evening so far
uh thanks john well written
well written i like that one um let me
thank
good people as she wraps up here nils
fensky is new member number 10 today
uh paul berg is new member number 11.
stephanie heinz is number 12.
joshua murphy is number 13. ashley
o'neill
is number 14 and gene
coronel is number 15 15 folks have
signed up at joinpackman.com
love it love it uh also thanks to
everybody watching on twitch
and um people on twitch asking for
pieces of my hair
oh my god that's weird kyle johnson says
so let me get this straight they heard
nothing about the policies but here's a
breakdown of the policies they presented
which is it yes
ronna mcdaniel's speech is if you watch
the dnc you heard no policy whatsoever
and here's why all of the policies are
terrible and radically liberal
dan samo flange says 20 bucks says that
the gun
couple bring their guns when they speak
tonight that's interesting
okay people watching so you may or may
not have heard that the couple who
brandished firearms against protesters
in st
louis is speaking tonight they are
speaking tonight
um who thinks they bring their guns out
and who thinks they don't that's a
beautiful question i
assume even though they're all about
guns at the rnc
all of these facilities are gun-free
zones interestingly enough
so my bet is no gun no gun i think
desiree dewitt says david i'm with you
this is pathetic
and unbearable tristan mccoppen says
everyone's forgotten covet 19 numbers
are suppressed or have they leaked
love to know your thoughts i don't trust
the coronavirus numbers we're getting at
this point
just that i i think that they are
understated
given everything we know that that's
gone on that's my sense of it
thanks to mr blunderful for the twitch
prime subscription
also bugsy's evil deeds
we are continuing here and building
towards some kind of crescendo
what that will be like is anyone's guess
assad katib says curious i moved to
florida a couple of years ago would my
vote for biden make a difference in this
red state yes
extremely important announcement
this is not an election to mess around
with staying home
or third party because you're in a very
blue state
or you're in a very red state we need to
run up the score
okay the bigger the gap
for the popular vote for joe biden if he
wins the popular vote
the more difficult it will be to
generate a situation where
some judge might say
this state should go you know the
florida 2000 type stuff okay so
we need to run the score up i'm voting
in massachusetts
biden's going to crush well he'll crush
by one more
because of me every state we've got to
run it up
yes okay very good um derek 10 says
mussolini would have loved the sick
panning shots
yeah these videos are vile
truly truly vile um
people asking what the coupon code is so
there's two so the the regular coupon
code is 2020 now
the special coupon code at
joinpakman.com is 15
year that's one five year celebrating
our 15th anniversary which we celebrated
yesterday although i got the date wrong
it's embarrassing but it's true it was
really august 17th
so um we celebrated it yesterday you can
still use the coupon code
15 year if you would like
uh kivo says late term abortions are bad
but when 170 000 diet is what it is
beautifully said beautifully said kyle
downey says i'm for bernie
but voting by for biden a correct
assessment i appreciate that
um other super chats jacob ratner
donald trump says he wants 12 years yet
these people say biden is a threat to
democracy the projection oh my god
oml oml i don't remember what oml
means um
oh just does it as a quick uh memetic
interjection here just to
bring a little bit of uh you know levity
someone sent me this today they say this
is
me ripped after working out it does sort
of look like me it's very interesting
isn't it
what do you guys think about this this
would fall under the other memes
category um
anyway if people want to use this to
generate additional memetic content
please let me know but uh yeah anyway
this was me at my gym the other day
all right back to the insanity back to
the insanity
um
yeah it's a it's a disturbing video for
sure
welcome to everybody just joining us if
you're watching on
youtube or twitch we started about 10
minutes before the start of this fiasco
and we are going to do the best we can
to make it to the end
it is difficult it is very very
difficult
but we're going to try to do it i really
do appreciate the people keeping us
going
with the website memberships matthew
stromer
is new member number 16. maribel
finnen is number 17.
um shannon morgan is number 18
martin feif is number 19.
very much appreciate that joinpakman.com
is available at your disposal
we are waiting for jim jordan we are
waiting for
who else is scheduled for today let's
review senator tim scott
we're gonna hear from steve scalise we
heard already from matt gates jim jordan
will be speaking
nikki haley we already heard from ronna
mcdaniel
um we heard from charlie blork
who else we heard from tanya winerice we
heard from cardinal dolan
so and maybe we heard from rebecca
friedrichs already
okay here's someone so it felt right to
follow in my mother's footsteps and
become a nurse
and this march when covent 19 sent our
country into crisis
i knew i had to help any way that i
could i deployed to new york in april
and then to san antonio texas working as
a covert relief nurse
in both states as i contended with the
challenges of treating our patients
who had their worlds turned upside down
i noticed a positive change in our
health care system
president trump recognized the threat
this virus presented for all americans
early on
and made rapid policy changes and as a
result
telehealth services are now accessible
to more than 71 million americans
including 35 million children
prior to covid telehealth was not
covered
or reimbursed under medicare medicaid
or chip this left our most vulnerable
populations
with no other choice but to have an
in-person
office visit with their physicians
increasing their risk of exposure to
covenants i know people want to hear
this one trust me guys i can tell i i
can tell
i'm taking the temperature of the chat
we're gonna we're gonna hear the whole
thing integration of video visits
between patients and their families
allowing loved ones
to have contact and visualization as
well as a better understanding of care
telehealth has been essential during
this pandemic
i don't want the media taking my
personal story and twisting it
so let me be clear okay as a health care
professional
i can tell you without hesitation donald
trump's quick action
and leadership saved thousands of lives
during covenanting
and the benefits of that response it
saved thousands but
cost about 80 000. health will continue
to aid many that are just unable to find
transportation or away to the doctor for
regular checkups
this is especially true in rural america
i live in a town of about 2 000 people
we do not have buses
trains trolleys or ubers available to us
in addition the unavailability of
services can also hinder treatment for
many
so increased access to telehealth for
millions of americans
has truly been life-saving and we have
president trump to thank
this is crazy
oh my god that was absolutely insane
thanks philip for the 50 super chat by
the way
who says it's honestly all about bad tap
water
all the monsanto spray and the amd gmo
seeds combined means the entire missouri
mississippi river
basin from north dakota to louisiana
is nothing but tap bad tap water and
lots of stupid
people oh my god that's very aggressive
that's extremely aggressive
quadrophenia asks what i think about the
brett weinstein unity 2020 campaign
i'll think about it for 2024. the next
president's going to be trump or biden
so i'm focused in on that rather than
sort of hypothetical um you know
third party runs or or whatever courtney
pollock says zero people of color donald
trump's american dream no tim scott is
going to speak and i think another black
guy
um so they are definitely including
diversity plus that last woman
um uh some people in the chat were
saying
might not have been white but like
really who cares i don't really do
identity politics stuff
kumar says both aoc or ayok
as i call her and bernie stressed the
importance of biden win she tweeted for
biden to win in november after day one
of dnc
i'm a yang guy voting for biden
disco mutt says this speech is an
auditory lobotomy i've
i'm down three iq points uh it was two
from charlie blork
and then one from that last speech so so
far i've lost
three iq points during this thing george
ruth
says i work for an insurance company
telehealth was a product of private
health care not the government of course
of course it was um let's see what's
happening on twitch
anti-social lev has subscribed with
prime
rika25 has subscribed with prime
brent stone has subscribed and says no
one else i'd rather help distribute
bezos money
to keep up what you do beautiful
absolutely love it this might be a skip
uh do we know who this gentleman is
decisive leadership
led to a rapid and efficient response to
the coronavirus pandemic oh my god
i know this as a health professional and
as someone who has recovered from covet
himself
the covid19 pandemic exploded into our
great nation
with an intensity unparalleled in
history
but our medical investigation and drug
development systems
were not designed for a pandemic the
devastating effects of the coronavirus
demanded immediate changes
remember that we had systems for the
pandemic like the pandemic response
team and the 69-page color-coded
playbook they were disbanded and thrown
in the trash
drug approvals a long and drawn-out
process
by harnessing the resources of the
federal government
in the private sector president trump's
operation warp speed
is accelerating the testing supply
development
and distribution of therapeutics
diagnostics
and very shortly effective vaccines to
counter covet 19.
okay let me give you three clear
examples
of how president trump's leadership
removed regulatory barriers
so covet patients could have faster
access to effective therapies and
diagnostics
first on february 26th two
phase three clinical trials studying rem
desevere
were initiated just two months later
that was when trump was bragging about
hydroxy
and now they're going back there were
like 12 drugs this is sort of like a
pick your winners thing
there was like a blanket authorization
for about 10 or 12 different things
this is such revisionist history second
the fda granted expanded access to
covid19 convalescent plasma
within 24 hours of this approval we were
administering
convalescent plasma in room desevere to
a critically ill
patient a former army ranger
and physician had it not been for the
rapid deployment of these medicines
this patient who is my colleague and
friend
would have surely died i don't know that
you can even say that like is that a
is that an empirical claim developed a
fever and cough
i reached out to our testing team and
received one
of the abbott rapid tests yet another
tool quickly approved by this
administration
within 15 minutes my test came back
positive
and within four hours i was receiving my
room desevere doses
followed by an infusion of convalescent
plasma
plasma as a physician i've seen
firsthand how these breakthroughs have
saved countless lives
as a patient i've benefited from the
expedited therapies made possible by the
swift action of this administration
president trump truly moved mountains to
save lives
so i think this is an important moment
to mention
that like only an acutely
only if you're trying to kill people
would a world leader in a situation like
this
not do what public health officials say
from the standpoint of just authorizing
treatments like obviously trump didn't
shut down the economy or suggest it be
shut down or mask or anything until it
was too late
every country is using all this same
stuff like there's nothing
interesting or special to say donnie did
a big boy
with the convalescent plasma thing i
have relatives in argentina
with coronavirus who could get
convalescent plasma if they got sick
enough like it just it doesn't have
anything to do with donald trump and
claiming that is a reason to re-elect
him is downright bizarre
truly truly bizarre but they've got
nothing else
that's the thing they have to say well
trump did plasma you know
um
okay people misunderstanding what i'm
saying is really weird
richard buckley says why are all these
people not talking about how covet is
just the flu now they see covet as a big
problem yeah which trump solved right
spicy meat paul says how isn't footage
from trump earlier this year calling
covet a democ
democratic hoax plastered everywhere how
isn't that among the dems ads thanks
david it should be
it should be for sure um
wptw says dnc only talked about trump
rnc attacks citizens let's see what this
is
we can call it many different things
from china virus i don't want to go
through all the names because some
people may get insulted but that's the
way it is
these are great great people doctors
nurses
firemen uh policemen we want to thank
you all you've been
incredible and we want to thank you and
all of the millions
look at him hinging forward at the hips
well very much great job
thank you thank you thank you all very
much so tell me a little about your
stories how about we'll start with you
oh my god this is trump having been
coached to try to be a normal person
they're literally copying what joe biden
did these sort of like round table panel
type things it's just it's just copying
believe me we're not getting rid of our
postal workers you know they'd like to
sort of put that out there if anyone
does it's the democrats not the
republicans i want to thank you very
much and thank
everybody in that whole beautiful post
office system we appreciate it
how about you i'm a trucker good owned a
small business in ohio
great uh rolling steel mostly um
you know some of our customers actually
made hospital beds with uh
material that's fantastic well
congratulations i love the truckers you
know they're on my side
thank you i think all of them frankly i
think pretty much all of them
not the ones that call my show custodian
at the post office as well
what do you do exactly clean up
everybody's mess and everybody's journey
trump doesn't know the word custodian so
he has to say what exactly do you do
normal people understand what a
custodian does thank you very much for
being here thank you thank you and how
about you
i'm a registered nurse president trump i
uh work at a new jersey hospital
called willing hospital right um i also
represent an organization of
professional nurses
trump's got to unlock those knees or
he's going to have a problem but i want
to tell you sir as a nursing supervisor
i am so in awe of your leadership
honestly um
i know many people have said often
interesting things but
why is it it takes a true leader to be
able to ignore all that stuff and do
what is right
and not be offended by all the words
being said and
you really do show that positive spirit
to us and as nurses i appreciate that
but just as an individual
i'm grateful for that well i'm for the
nurses i'm for the doctors i'm for
everybody
we just have to make this china virus go
away and it's happening
please go ahead i'm also a nurse i
represent genesis healthcare which is a
skill nursing facility
company i want to thank you and your
administration for all the supplies and
support
and funding that you've given the
skilled nursing units
without that we couldn't he doesn't even
know how to be thanked
i spent some time in new jersey i live
in west virginia went to new jersey
and did some work there and we finally
started to see things change and turn
around i appreciate what you said
because
you have delivered billions of dollars
of equipment that governors were
supposed to give and in many cases
they didn't get so the federal
government i this is
this is way more entertaining than the
dnc i mean it's a signal of the downfall
of our country's entire educational and
cognitive
uh capacity system but it's far more
entertaining we're in englewood colorado
and i contracted covid in late march
cool batteries that means we don't have
to be afraid of you at all
once you're recovered you know we have
the whole thing with plasma happening
plasma that means your blood is very
valuable you know that right
thank you very much great please i'm a
detention deputy the kern county
sheriff's department out in california
great and uh i also contracted coven
um into march and recovered from that
also how long was your
problem um i was sick about 10 days
really bad i got everything besides the
cough
but recovered i was off work for a month
and a half and i work in our local
county jails
did they do anything specifically to
help you recover they gave me zpax
medication
cough syrup okay and i won't even ask
you about the hydroxychloroquine because
because it's a shame what they've done
to that one but
well this one i took it i took the z
pack also and zinc
i want to thank you all very much it's
an honor to have you in the white house
you're a fantastic people and the people
you represent you represent
an incredible group of people and we
love you all
thank you very much thank you very much
appreciate it
good evening i'm congressman jim jordan
representing the fourth district of ohio
the republican party is the pro-america
party president trump is the pro-america
candidate
this election is about who can preserve
the values principles
and institutions that make america great
don't believe me
look at what's happening in american
cities cities all run by democrats
crime violence and mob rule democrats
refuse to denounce the mob
and their response to the chaos defund
the police
defund border patrol and defund our
military and while they're doing all
this
they're also trying to take away your
guns look at the positions they've taken
in the past few months
democrats won't let you go to church but
they'll let you protest
democrats won't let you go to work but
they'll let you riot
and democrats won't let you go to school
remember churches wanted to be able to
take coveted money
and so but they wanted to have it both
ways when it comes to
are they essential or not do they get
covered money or not and then these guys
like to say oh democrats just didn't
want you to pray
trump fights back they tried the russia
hoax the mueller investigation
and the fake impeachment but in spite of
this unbelievable opposition
this president has done what he said he
would do taxes cut
regulations reduced economy growing
lowest unemployment 50 years out of the
iran deal embassy in jerusalem hostages
home from north korea
and unemployment's like 13 right now of
course he's building the wall
and rebuilding our economy as we speak i
love the president's intensity and his
willingness to fight
every day in washington for our families
but what i also appreciate about the
president
is something most americans never get to
see yeah how much he truly cares about
people
our family has seen it two years ago our
nephew eli was killed in a car accident
he lived a mile up the road from us grew
up wrestling and training with our boys
was a high school state champion varsity
athlete for the university jordan's back
back story with wrestling is not good
three days after the accident
i walked to the car to head up to eli's
parents home when the president called
we talked about a few issues and then he
asked how the family was doing
i said they're doing okay mr president
but it's tough
the president said yeah losing a loved
one is always difficult
and it's really tough when they're so
young i then said mr president i'm
actually walking into their house right
now
obviously they don't know that i'm
talking to you but if you'd be willing
to say hello to eli's dad
you'd make a terrible day a little less
terrible what's his name the president
asked
i walked through the door and said todd
the president wants to talk to you
powerful story right minutes family and
friends sat in complete silence
as the president of the united states
took time to talk to a dad who was
hurting
that's the president i've gotten to know
the last four years
the president shared private moments
like this with soldiers
victims of violent crime and people
who've had businesses destroyed by the
mob
that's the individual who's made america
great again and who knows america's best
days are still in front of us
and that's why i'm busting my tail to
help him get reelected
i'm asking you to do the same thank you
and god bless our country
i'm not an actor a singer or a
politician
i'm hershel walker most of you know me
as a football player
but i'm also a father a man of faith
and a very good judge of character yeah
i've known donald trump for 37 years
and i don't mean just casual ranting to
him from time to time
i'm talking about a deep personal
friendship
i watched him as an owner of a
professional football team
right after he bought the team he set
out to learn
he learned about the history of the team
the players the coaches
every detail then he used what he
learned to make the team better
i watched him in the board room he can
be in the middle of a big meeting
but if one of the kids was on the phone
he dropped everything to take the call
he taught me that the family should be
your top priority
i watch him treat janitors security
guards and wait
who's he talking about doesn't sound
like trump he made them
special because he knew they were he
understands that they are the people who
make this country run
they clean they cook they build they
drive
they deliver he told me herschel
make an effort to get to know people
remember their names
that stuck with me one time i planned to
take his kids to disney world with my
family
at the last minute donald said he'd like
to join us
so there he was in a business suit on uh
it's a small world ride that was
something to see
it just showed you what a caring loving
father he is
it hurt my soul to hear the terrible
names that people call
donald the worst one is racist
i take it as a personal insult that
people would think i've had a 37-year
friendship with the races
why would that be weird people think
that don't know what they're talking
about
growing up in the deep south i've seen
racism up close
by the way weren't republicans against
identity politics i could have sworn
that
because someone loves and respect the
flag our national anthem and our country
doesn't mean they don't care about
social justice i care about all those
things
so does donald trump he shows how much
he cares about social justice in the
black community through his actions
and his actions speaks louder than
stickers or slogans on a jersey
he keeps right on fight and to improve
the lives of black americans
and all americans he works night and day
he never stops he leaves nothing on the
field
some people don't like his style the way
he knocks down obstacles that get in the
way of his goals
people on an opposing team that like
when i ran over them either
but that's how you get the job done i
pray every night that god gives him more
time
no god give him four more years hope
god's not listening he has accomplished
so much
almost all by himself on a constant
attack
but there's still more work to be done
if you love america and want to make it
better
donald trump is your president he's my
president
and i'm blessed to call him friend
good evening i'm natalie harp a formerly
forgotten american from california
okay we're gonna mute this one for a bit
we've done a few in a row
um oh my god i mean this
this is going to be a battle to make it
until the end we've still got
a hundred minutes to go of this complete
and utter insanity
um poopy man says on twitch
if trump is saying he took a z pack in
zinc is he admitting he had kovid i
i wondered the same thing
this is crazy um this is a great time to
get super chats in if you're watching on
youtube
jim adelberg says traumatic brain injury
must suck well we don't know that that's
rude
breadchaser says jim jordan reminds me
of jordan chase from dexter
ian jones says is there any hypothetical
scenario you support a third party
candidate
in 2020 like late progressive candidate
with massive momentum uh you're you're
you're
in a fantasy world it's going to be
biden or trump i'm voting biden
cyrex says and on the third day god
created the remington bolt action rifle
so that man could fight the dinosaurs
and the homosexuals
that's that's good i like that that's
very solid um
if you're just joining us we are all
together in an
active community trying to survive just
the first hour of what are going to be
10 hours of this this week it's
absolutely
insane if you are watching on youtube
please consider yourself invited to hit
the subscribe button
we are just 800 subscribers from 965
k you understand now 965
000 and we have 13 000 people watching
so let's do the beautiful thing let's do
965 000.
really really love it um
philip naumann says bad tap water bronx
bjorn says if you look real close he
looks terrified he might be caught
blinking out morse code the token
southern african-american oh my god
nicole says david you're the only person
getting me through this please don't
quit
lol i need you i tell the same things
you
do best watching tv by myself ever
bread chaser says this is all about
praising trump of course
of course trump will be praised trump
must be praised
uh desiree dewitt says david i'm or no
i'm sorry
thank you sir for plasma and rum
reservoir
yes um trump has dramatically lowered
fatalities by giving yoseminites
plasma and rum reservoir
this is not the figure skater tanya
harding no for people asking
nils fensky says david i'm worried i
don't think your whole audience has
enough iq points combined for this
by the end we may all be trump voters
yeah i announced a few minutes ago i've
lost
three iq points just in the first 55
minutes of this so far
so i'm gonna need i'm gonna need
something maybe a z-pack i don't even
know hydroxy or a bleach injection to
boost it
because i am losing iq points by the
minute let me say thank you to people
who are supporting the show on my
website
bridget stehovic is new member number
20. lita mchugh is number 21.
kimberly carranza is number 22.
jack rodriguez is 23. kyle mcgee
is 24 and yaya
is number 25 and you know that when we
get to 25 i like to say let's go for 50.
why not why not let's go for 50.
tristan michelle says trump was sued by
the nixon administration for racism
that's true
anan says i feel like i'm trapped on my
racist grandpa's fever dream
after he passed out in front of fox news
from eating an inappropriate amount of
hot dogs
not unlike what i'm experiencing right
now
i will admit that a thanks to
sf city for subscribing on twitch as
well as
anthonyw and bitchin
kitchen has subscribed at tier one
um it looks like this individual is
rapping let's see
who is next uh and maybe it would be
something
we want to listen to we're still waiting
for tim scott
um
okay hello america my name is vernon
jones
and i'm a state representative from the
great state of georgia
as you can see i'm a man of color
and i'm a lifelong democrat too wow you
may be wondering
why is a lifelong democrat speaking at
the republican national convention
and that's a fair question and here's
your answer
the democratic party does not want black
people to leave their mental plantation
we've been forced to be there for
decades and generations
oh my gosh but i have news for joe biden
we are free we are free people with free
minds
and i'm part of the light of identity
politics of the black community
who are independent thinkers and we
believe that donald trump
is the president that america needs to
lead us forward
this is no time for sleeping in the
basement joe biden has had
47 years to produce results
but he's been all talk and no action
just like so many of the democrats
who've been making promises
to the black voters for decades okay
we've been their captive
audience when president trump sought to
earn the black
vote the democratic party leaders went
crazy
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer literally
started wearing kente cloths around
the u.s capitol as if pandering
were enough to keep us satisfied
let me tell you why i'm supporting our
president yeah it's not clear i grew up
in the south
in laurel hill north carolina scotland
county
the green pond community to be exact
my parents robin and roofer jones built
with their own hands
a four-room cinderblock home with no
indoor plumbing
they had very limited education but they
instilled in us
a strong work ethic that drove me from
those tobacco fields of north carolina
to those hallowed halls of the georgia
general assembly
okay my parents taught me if i believed
in god
worked hard and treated every person
fairly
there was no limit to what we could
achieve
i attended north carolina central
university
and historical black college for
generations
hbcus have been the incubators that
develop black scholars
in math and science and religion
engineering
and politics they have been imported
springboards
for the black but democrats haven't
treated them that way
when president trump took office he
changed everything
he delivered historic funding to hbcus
and he guaranteed it for 10 years
something has never happened
in the history of this country that gave
our hbcus
stability the chance to grow and produce
the next generation of black leaders
that's right
donald trump did that powerful story
he's also
supported school choice to ensure that
no child
no matter their race or zip code is left
behind
every child should have access to a
quality education
but education is just the beginning the
president also built the most inclusive
economy
ever with record low unemployment for
african americans
and record high participation in the
workforce
he put opportunity zones in the trump
tax bill
that would drive investment into our
communities for decades to come
he put the interests of american workers
and especially
black workers first that's right
donald trump did that
he delivered historic criminal justice
reform
he ended once and for all the policy of
incarceration
of black people which has decimated our
communities caused by no other than joe
biden
you might be wondering how didn't i hear
about any of this stuff that trump did
and it's because
he didn't do it and joe biden and kamala
harris definitely wouldn't do it
but donald trump did it he's also
working
every day to make our community safer as
a former
executive of dekalb county georgia
i directed one of the largest public
safety departments in the southeast
i've seen tragic shootings on both sides
officers killing citizens and citizens
killing officers in the line of duty
police officers are fellow citizens they
live in our country
they have families too they live in our
communities
unfortunately democrats have turned
their backs
on our brave police officers they call
it defunding and it's a danger to our
cities
our neighborhoods and our children
isn't it ironic that democrat
politicians have personal security
to protect them so why don't they forego
their security and replace them with
social workers
especially how is that at all logical
for you and me
our police need more funding not less i
don't know if he knows the definition of
irony
for non-lethal remote restraint
technology
and for more de-escalation and use of
force training
these are the common sense solutions
that president trump supports
true sincere police reform that's right
donald trump did that too education
jobs safety security
on issue after issue and in just a
single
term he destroyed these negative forces
that have victimized
the black community for decades
he gave us the opportunity to rise
now you know when i made the public
announcement of my support for president
trump
yeah nobody cares all hell broke loose
nobody cared
i was threatened called an embarrassment
and asked to resign by my own party okay
all that is true
unfortunately that's consistent
with the democratic party and how they
view
independent thinking black men and women
no it's how we view people who make
political decisions that make no sense
unless there's some weird explanation
we've not been told
louder than ever
the democratic party has become infected
with a pandemic of intolerance
bigotry socialism
anti-law enforcement bias and a
dangerous tolerance for people
who attack others destroy their property
and terrorize our own communities
that's what this election is all about
and that's why right now more than ever
more than ever before america needs
donald
trump in the oval office for another
four years
god bless you and vote donald j trump
thank you wow
what a disastrous speech this is a great
time to get your
um super chats in
i don't know if we're gonna be doing
this one
um royal empire vlog says he's a paid
actor trump hasn't done any of what he's
saying no
certainly certainly not um
yabbot says ronald reagan asked in 1980
are you better off than you were four
years ago
are you enough said says thank you eric
lavanier
says charlie kirk started the rnc saying
the dnc didn't talk about policy
i haven't heard a single policy so far
tonight
am i really here says trump doesn't even
know how to be near children much less
care about them
poor other token black man
okay a freshman girl to protect her
she draped her body over her and then
the scumbag gunman
shot my daughter at point blank range
five more times
killing meadow and the girl she was
shielding
she had a whole life ahead of her and in
that life
she could have done anything and been
anything
so many moments that i waited so long
for were taken from me
i didn't get to drop her off at college
i didn't get to walk her down the aisle
but every moment was taken from her and
for what
i never wanted this to become a
political spectacle but it did
i never wanted to meet the president
like this but i did
i was invited to the white house the
truth is i
just buried my daughter that week i
really wasn't interested in public
events like a tour or a photo op
i was interested in answers and
solutions so if the president wanted to
meet me personally i said i'd go
they said of course that was his plan
at the white house my family and i sat
with the president in the oval office
and told him about meadow
i told him what we knew i told him that
his administration
needed to take a closer look at what
went wrong and why
and i got to see who president trump
really is
he's a good man and a great listener and
he cuts through the bs
then the president did what he said he
would do he took action
he formed the school safety commission
that issued dozens of recommendations to
make schools safer
but i'll bet you never heard about that
instead
the media turned my daughter's murder
went to a coordinated attack on
president trump
republicans and our second amendment
in fact when president trump asked me
and other parents of children
that were murdered in school shootings
to join him as he announced the
commission's findings
the media's first question wasn't about
protecting kids
shockingly they asked about the
government shutdown
president trump turned to me appalled
and said andy
can you believe these people we're
trying to talk about school safety
and this is what they do but i could
believe it
after my daughter's murder the media
didn't seem interested in the facts
wouldn't this be the perfect guy to say
we need gun safety regulations troll
laws didn't fail my daughter
people did the gunman had threatened to
kill his classmates before
he had threatened to rape them he had
threatened to shoot up the school
every red flag you could imagine but the
school didn't just miss these red flags
they knowingly ignored them
far left democrats in our school
district made this shooting possible
because they implemented something they
called restorative justice
this policy which really just blames
teachers for students failures
puts kids and teachers at risk and makes
shootings more likely
but it was billed as a this is obviously
crazy but what i'm thinking of is like
if you're
in some way undecided and you see this
guy does this guy convince you to vote
for trump
it was called discipline and safety but
the obama biden administration took
parkland's bad policies
and forced them into schools across
america
when president trump rescinded obama's
guidance on restorative justice policies
he put an end to that and that meant the
world to me
it's hard to tell how much mr biden
understands about what happened
at parkland mr biden has campaigned on
bringing back restorative justice
as part of as part of his unity platform
with bernie sanders and has pledged to
implement in school districts across
america
okay but he doesn't even seem to know
when the shooting happened
he said that he was vice president when
it happened but he wasn't
mr biden may not know when my daughter
was murdered but i do
february 14 2018.
mr biden may not know that these
policies make shootings more likely but
i do
mr biden may not know who was vice
president that day but i do
it wasn't joe biden it was mike pence
thank god and i know who the president
was too
it wasn't barack obama it was president
donald j
trump and he took action
i truly believe the safety of our kids
depends on whether this man is
re-elected
i hope you'll join me in helping to make
that happen in the opposite way though
mr president myself and millions of
americans appreciate you
and love you god bless america and god
bless our
president donald j trump thank you
i would be the last person to tell this
guy that he's grieving the loss of his
daughter incorrectly
i just don't understand the connection
to why anybody would vote trump on the
basis of what that guy
experienced it actually seems crazy
let me say a few thank yous elliot chase
is new member number 26
today mary foreman is number 27.
rebecca christiansen is number 28.
rosalba rios
is number 29. salman khan
is huh that's interesting is number 30.
i wonder i mean i guess that's a pretty
common name but
could that possibly be sal khan from
khan academy that's that would be very
very interesting
um okay oh oh oh is this is this st
louis
defending our home as a mob of
protesters descended on our neighborhood
america is such a great country that not
only do you have the right to own a gun
and use it to defend yourself but
thousands
of americans will offer you free advice
on how to use it
at least that's what we experienced
these people are horrible what you saw
happen to us
could just as easily happen to any of
you who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods
around our country and that's what we
want to speak to you
about tonight that's exactly right
whether it's the defunding of police
ending cash understand that had they not
pointed guns at protesters protesting
against police brutality they wouldn't
be here today
we're encouraging anarchy and chaos on
our streets
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the
out-of-control mob you saw at our house
was charged with a crime but you know
who was
did they commit any crime we were
they've actually charged us with
felonies
for daring to defend our home didn't
they brandon on top of that
consider this the marxist liberal
activist
leading the mob to our neighborhood
stood outside our home
with a ball horn screaming you can't
stop the revolution
just weeks later that same marxist
activist
won the democrat nomination to hold a
seat in the u.s
house of representatives in the city of
saint louis
that's the same as winning the general
election that marxist
revolutionary is now going to be the
congresswoman from the first
district of missouri these radicals are
not content with marching in the streets
they want to walk the halls of congress
they want to take over
they want power most activists want to
be part of institutional power yeah
that's like not really a huge
bang they're not satisfied with
spreading the chaos and violence
into our communities they want to
abolish the suburbs all together
by ending single-family home zoning this
forestry zoning would bring crime
lawlessness and low-quality apartments
into now thriving suburban neighborhoods
president trump smartly ended this
government overreach
but joe biden wants to bring it back
these are the policies that are coming
to a neighborhood near you
so make no mistake no matter where you
live
your family will not be safe in the
radical democrats
america seems like a parody at this
moment in history
if you stand up for yourself and for the
values our country was founded on
the mob spurred on by their allies in
the media
will try to destroy you you've seen us
on your tv screens and twitter feeds
you know that we're not the kind of
people who back down is
any of this live there is donald trump
president trump will defend the
god-given right
of every american to protect their homes
and their families but more than that
trump's vision for america
is a country where you have an
opportunity to work hard
and build the life you dream of with a
job you love
with your children being educated in
great schools
in a community where your family can
play in the backyard without fear
worship in a church without shame and
express
your beliefs without retribution
trump brought us the greatest economy
our country had ever seen
it's insane that these people are here
merely because they pointed guns at
others
when we don't have basic safety and
security in our communities
we'll never be free to build a brighter
future for ourselves
for our children or for our country
that's what's at stake in this election
and that's why we must re-elect donald
trump
okay god bless you god bless the
president
and god bless you the united states
and now it's kimberly guilfoyle
recovered from covet 19.
good evening america i'm kimberly
guilfoyle
i speak to you tonight as a mother a
former prosecutor
a latina and a proud american
and yes a proud supporter of president
donald j
trump cringe why because he is the
president
who delivers for america and i'm dating
a son the greatest economy the world has
ever known
for the strivers the working class and
middle class
as commander-in-chief he always puts
america first
president trump is the law and order
president
now presidential leadership is not
guaranteed
it is a choice biden harris and the rest
of the socialists will fundamentally
change this nation they want open
borders closed schools
dangerous amnesty and will selfishly
send your jobs back to
china while they get rich they will
defund
dismantle and destroy america's law
enforcement
when you are in trouble any police
don't count on the democrats this seems
like snl
you couldn't parody this because it's it
would be no crazier
their socialist agenda is my mother
mercedes was a special education teacher
from aguadilla puerto rico
my father also an immigrant came to this
nation in pursuit of the american dream
now i consider it my duty to fight to
protect
that dream rioters must not be allowed
to destroy our cities
human sex drug traffickers should not be
allowed to cross our border
the same socialist policies which
destroyed
places like cuba and venezuela
must not take root in our cities right
remember there's no risk that that's
going to happen
want to see the socialist biden harris
future for our country
yeah neither biden or harris or even
close to socialists
it is a place of immense wealth
immeasurable innovation
an immaculate environment and the
democrats turned it into a land of
discarded heroin needles in parks
riots and streets and blackouts in homes
in president trump's america we light
things up
we don't dim them down we build things
up
we don't burn them down it's like a
preacher we kneel
in prayer and we stand for
our flag
this election is a battle for the soul
of america
your choice is clear
do you support the cancel culture
the cosmopolitan elites of nancy pelosi
chuck schumer and joe biden
who blame america first this is crazy do
you
think america is to blame
or do you believe in american greatness
believe in yourself
in president trump in individual and
personal responsibility
they want to destroy this country
and everything that we have fought for
and hold dear
they want to steal your liberty your
freedom
they want to control what you see and
think and believe so that they can
control
how you live
they want to enslave you to the weak
dependent
liberal victim ideology to the point
that you will not recognize
this country or yourself
from the beginning when president trump
spoke about
making america great again
he was speaking about that shining city
on a hill
and restoring the beacon of light that
once shined
so bright his promise was to put
america first and he has
when president trump cut middle class
taxes putting tens of thousands of
dollars back in the pockets of working
class americans
yes she aware there's cameras in the
room occur once again
when president trump commanded the
defeat of isis
took out al-baghdadi and solomoni and
paved the way for
peace in the middle east that beacon
started to glow
when he negotiated historic trade deals
with canada
mexico japan and china should i just
switch to that whenever it gets really
bad
bring jobs to america that beacon shined
bright once again for the world to see
america it's all on the line
president trump believes in you he
emancipates and lifts you
up to live your if you saw someone doing
this on the subway it would probably
qualify for a 72-hour cycle
all right you are powerful and you have
the ability
to choose your life and determine your
destiny don't let the democrats take you
for granted
don't let them step on you don't let
them destroy your families your lives
and your future
don't let them kill future generations
because they told you and brainwashed
you
and fed you lies that you weren't good
enough
like my parents you can achieve your
american dream
you can be that shining example to the
world
manifest and be the change in this
country that you dream
that you hope that you believe in i
almost feel like i need to more
regularly mention that i'm hispanic
clearly this is teaching me i'm not
mentioning it enough loves
this country and will fight for her
president trump is the leader who will
rebuild the promise of america
and ensure that every citizen can
realize their american dream
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom and liberty
and the american dream the best
is yet to come
[Music]
was this a medical event
oh my god
wow i've never seen anything like that
i think i need to tweet about this right
like i need to say something about it
um
watching this republican convention
is really making me think i need to be
constantly mentioning
that i'm hispanic in
absolutely any
situation regardless of whether
it's relevant
wow what a cr wow wow
um okay this is steve scalise we're
gonna skip steve scalise because i
we need to cool down just a little bit
let me see what people are saying via
super chat if you have thoughts
i i want to specifically take super
chats on kimberly guilfoyle's rant
uh oh my god tyler lin says how much of
this event is motivated by mendacity and
how much of it is driven by stupidity
and blind faith it's hard to put a
specific finger you know numbers on it
do you think these people believe the
things they're saying many of them don't
nicole just projectile vomit
uh john good friend says david don't you
think kimberly looks like the creature
from black lagoon i don't want to focus
on her physical appearance what she said
is crazy
um okay incomplete joker thinks that was
a sexual experience for her
miguel is just in a wtf situation
uh some people think that there were
drugs involved there
uh i think so far the funniest is nicole
with a just projectile vomited
we have a user chakuseki who's very
clever
and may come in soon with a funny super
chat
plexus says your country is not well i
am so sorry yeah
i mean listen if there's anything good
about this
it's that people seem to be
understanding how
how bad off we are and they're getting
memberships on my website and
recognizing we should support
independent media
curtis mort is new member 31 christine
stewart just signed up is number 32 at
joinedpakman.com dianna ellis is number
33
and david dillman is number 34
so i i really appreciate the support but
these people are not well
that was genuinely terrifying genuinely
terrifying
um oh my god i don't even know how to
react to that let's see
we i think we've got to go to david
pakman
workout guy deep fake to recover
oh my god okay let's calm let's all calm
down
oh man so okay beautiful question on
twitch
before kimberly guilfoyle spoke i had
lost
i estimate three iq points during this
event
i think i lost another four just from
kimberly alone so i'm down
seven points now and i'm trying to avoid
losing an eighth point which is why
we're not listening
to steve scalise right now mikhail
browning says she forgot her can
of goya beans uh okay negan's getting a
little too aggressive for this
we've we have kids that watch this with
their parents so we're not gonna do that
matt bond says can we build a wall
around these people and make it padded
the these people are out of their minds
this is
a and you know what you have to remember
is that somewhere between 60 and 68
million people
are gonna vote for this again a second
time
like even if trump loses he'll certainly
get 60 million votes
and if he wins he could get you know 66
67 68 million
uh here is who's this i don't even know
who this is
and it is an honor to be here in 2006
the army sent me to afghanistan as a
young platoon leader
placed in command of americans from
every corner of our planet
our platoon reflected the diversity of
our nation
every race creed and religion despite
those differences we were bound together
as brothers from the same american
family
on june 10 2006 our platoon was attacked
just after dawn
outnumbered ten to one we endured mortar
and machine gun fire as hundreds of
taliban charged us from three sides
we had 24 men that day wave
after guys how is it
are people watching from around the
world and
like how is the is anybody else
embarrassed
because this is embarrassing this is
just done
insane these people are crazy
this doesn't this doesn't make any sense
ajamul omowale is confused about
kimberly guilfoyle's parents
i'm going to have to talk about the
kimberly guilfoyle thing tomorrow on the
podcast
i'm confused about her parents
citizenships are her parents citizens
ux masitis as they're barely mentioning
covet i wonder why
quirky quip says hey i sent a super chat
quirky there have been so many
i'm trying to keep up with them but it's
really really tough we've got about 13
000 people watching and these super
chats are pouring in
they're just pouring in um
mac jaso says black conservatives are
the build-up to jesse lee peterson
amazing
annette dion says bad choice of speaker
with the bounties on soldiers there wtf
it's all going bad um people on twitch
are about to destroy all of their
their technology it looks we've got 1600
people watching on twitch
i think 700 people are about to throw
their phones in the trash another 700
are about to set their laptops on fire
and the 200 that are left have stepped
away and they're just not watching i
mean this is like
really really to call this weaponized
is an understatement weaponized doesn't
even begin to cover it
um okay all right i guess we'll listen a
little more to this
ain't you to conformity and will destroy
anyone they deem a heretic
i swore an oath to defend my country and
its constitution
president trump has sworn to do the same
that's why he's advanced
freedom despite savage political attacks
to overcome the agenda
of the radical left president trump has
unleashed the economic might of this
nation
like no other president in our history
he triggered the rising tide of working
families
brought us energy independence reclaimed
jobs from overseas that you know
democrats said would never return
he has fiercely defended the besieged
first and second amendments
that is just a start with four more
years
imagine what we can achieve by simply
working
with our president i believe in our
president's vision for the future
i stand here tonight calling on all
americans to join us
it doesn't matter what you look like who
you love how you worship your gender or
your job
if you're a traditional democrat who's
become disillusioned with how radical
your party has become
then stand with us you are most welcome
america needs all her patriots to rush
to her defense
holy [ __ ] my fellow americans i promise
you this
in our tent you are
free free to speak the truth
choose your journey define your life you
have the power to go as far as you aim
then aim higher
and keep going because that is what
americans do
we are idealists and dreamers lovers of
adventure we're rugged and independent
we don't make excuses we make the
impossible
a reality think about it in a century
we went from ground-bound dreamers
gazing to the stars
to doers who created the means to reach
them
this is not the time to stand on the
sidelines if you love our country as we
do
as our president does join the chorus of
patriot voices
that will preserve this exceptional
union mr president
lead the way millions in our american
family believe
in this path to destiny hey this is
funny
two simultaneous super chats about
drinking
mark said taking a shot every time
someone banned from
running a charity is on the screen betty
ford clinic is on speed dial
sean said uh tried taking a shot of
whiskey with every bs comment and
couldn't make it past matt gates yeah
um pacman's little bot says this has to
be snl the wig's coming off right
you can't do s snl can't do a show about
this
because how do you make it crazier for
the purposes of satire you can't do it
you can't do it thanks to tyson j miller
for the twitch prime subscription
always love those bezos bucks
um oh my god the super chats are coming
in faster than i can read them
uh people are mad
people want to laugh track chad okada
says
aloha from hawaii david any chance of
doing a deep dive on the personality
cult that the republican right has
become
i have an interview with a guy named
steven hassan about that
actually so we've uh we've dealt with
that
oh my god my twitter by the way is
exploding i didn't even i'm terrible on
twitter i sent a few tweets and some
people seem to be liking them
uh primarily this one
um i think crystal ball retweeted me and
it's probably giving it a boost
um wow i mean it's just crazy what's
going on here
um thomas busby says we're free as long
as we suck up to old donny boy
yeah very much so
um if you're just joining us you pro i
don't i mean listen
if you're sticking around people are
watching on average 10 and a half
minutes
on this stream and
that's i mean i get it i get why people
are bailing on average
after 10 minutes this is completely nuts
completely nuts
riley callahan says holy hell they
politicized the military
of course of course they would never
of course um wendy davis says i'm
originally from the bahamas i used to
think this was the greatest country on
earth now this country is an
embarrassment
it's an embarrassment under trump we can
start to repair i think it's important
for people not to forget that
thanks to bronx night for the twitch
prime subscription
um as a moment of zen
at any time when things get too intense
i go over
to deep fake jim david this is deep fake
jim david with a beard
um this was me after working on my lats
i feel like this cools everybody off to
a certain degree
when it gets really really bad during
the uh the rnc
um okay
ricardo sanchez in spanish remember guys
i'm hispanic i
i know the dnc the rnc taught me i have
to repeat that
saludos davit pacman this the nashville
tennessee
beautiful i love it love it
o.e despite all the crazy speakers trump
not knowing what a custodian does is
still the best part of the night that
was an amazing moment that was really an
amazing moment
k says condolences from australia
lil quinoa pacheto says my ulcer just
formed
its own ulcer i understand that
um yeah i i i'm shell-shocked
i'm shell-shocked here's the upside we
only have
57 minutes to go that's the upside
thanks to trevor shorman who's new
member number 35
today harpo from nsync
is number 36 today hunter knight
is number 37 robin edwards is new member
number 38.
stephanie bain is number 39.
chris and jenny s are number 40
and robert steger is number 41
and right i don't want to forget about
ryan wong ryan wong is number 42.
you can send a little tip uh
if you please by signing up at
joinpakman.com
42 people have done it okay oh here's
another one of these this is crazy
who were held hostage by various
countries
and i'm very pleased to let everybody
know that we brought back
over 50 hostages from 22 different
countries
this is straight up copied from biden's
dnc brian
and others and i will tell you we uh
we're very proud of the job we did but
i'd like to ask maybe uh pastor brunson
to say a few words so we can go through
and
just give us a little history of what
happened and how is life treating you
i was held in turkey for two years and
you took unprecedented steps actually to
secure my release and your
administration really fought for me
and i don't i think if you hadn't done
that i may still be in turkey
so i'm very grateful for 28 years right
they had you there for
they had you scheduled for a long time
andrew we had to get you back and i have
to say that
to me president erdogan was very good
and i know they had you scheduled for a
long time and you were a very innocent
person
and uh here ultimately after we had a
few conversations he agreed
so we appreciate that and we appreciate
the people of turkey and you still
appreciate the people of turkey i
understand right
we love the turkish people that's grace
it's great to have you back andrew thank
you
please mr president thank you for having
me thank you my name is sam goodwin i'm
from st louis missouri
i was held in syria for 63 days and uh
i'm i think i speak for my fellow former
hostages and detainees here when i say
i'm as grateful as i've ever been for
anything to be home safely
and uh thank you for the information and
opportunity to be here
uh particularly ambassador o'brien was
incredibly supportive and helpful to my
family
and i can't say enough nice things about
him thank you for promoting him
good and uh just really happy to be here
so thank you
we got your back you got him back yeah
we got you all back and we have
some more that we're working on right
now to get back that we better do please
go ahead
my name is michael white mr president i
do once again
it's an honor to be here honored to meet
you in person basically what had
happened with me
is this all chopped up really weirdly i
think you guys can probably tell it's
edited strangely you're trapped and i
was
apprehended there i went through a lot
in their injustice system in iranian
justice does the [ __ ] is an
oppressive extortionist terrorist regime
you know what i'm talking about
but what you did sir is you were able to
get me out of that prison in record
time it was amazing thank you very much
well thank you
please yeah my name is josh holt this is
my wife tammy yes
we were held hostage in venezuela for
two years i know very well um
and you you helped us get out uh senator
hatch worked with you very well on that
as well
um and it was a a great honor to be able
to meet you right when we got back
i remember a lot of people ask me what
was it like meeting president trump and
i just said i was
i was blown away i just got released
after two years then i'm shaking the
hand of the president in the oval office
i don't really remember a whole lot of
it
so it's nice to meet you again and it's
been great it's been great to be back
helping people through situations that
they've gone through and now we have
started our family well the great people
of utah really wanted me to do something
about the two of you
and we were able to do it and a little
bit of a miracle i think frankly
it was because it was a very hostile
period and
we appreciate everybody trump declares
things he did as miracles
they get you both back and are you
living in utah now i hope we're sold
that's good we'll say hello to the folks
in utah because they're great people
thank you very much congratulations
thank you please
brian spent an unexpected trip there in
india i was not going to india i was
going through india to nepal
i've been working for the last 18 years
but on behalf of my family myself thank
you
uh president trump for getting us out
again so basically this is just
the darkest moment people have to show
up and suck up to trump
uh your letter to my wife came and it
really gave her the hope and the peace
and it's great
from that time forward as more people
got involved especially the ambassador
there
in india things became more peaceful and
the hope
uh was there for the last four months
that we really would get to come home
because they had planned on keeping me
for uh three to five years
the original charge thing was three to
five years right and that was cleared
and then they came up with new charges
to do a seven-year
term india responded very well to my
request
so we appreciate that and i appreciate
everything y'all did
thank you all for being with us we have
a few more people we want to get back
and we will get them back and they'll be
back very soon thank you very much
appreciate it great stories
[Music]
hello my name is maximo alvarez
in miami florida okay so i just want to
mute the oh wait
this guy's not argentinian is he oh god
from his axe i'm not
oh my god please tell me he's not
argentinian he divides freedom from fear
it divides the past from the press from
the future
i know about the past
i was going to say the only conservative
latino folks in the u.s
tend to be cubans and this guy is cuban
okay listen
people are asking for me to make this uh
available the deep fake buff
jim david i can post a link to it right
now
in both youtube and twitch chat but i
need people to promise that you're gonna
make
other stuff with it i need i need people
to promise that you're gonna bring me
the beautiful memes and make other stuff
with it if i post it okay because i
don't want to just post it and then it
goes nowhere
i want by tomorrow morning uh creative
other stuff sent to me okay people are
saying yes okay
all right pasting it in youtube a few
times
and then now pasting it in twitch
okay that is the deep fake buff david
thing so people can run wild with it and
then send me links to stuff
via my website contact form um
oh qb highlights is asking do i think
trump will decline in the polls after
this you know you would think so
but life is not fair and 63 million
people voted for him in 2016
so who the hell knows negan the
cliffhanger says imagine spending two
years as a hostage
and then the first thing you have to do
when you come back is shake trump's hand
an ugly thought an ugly thought
neil merchant says your commentary is my
anchor
to sanity amidst the truly unhinged
ramblings of
all these trump sycophants congrats
again on 15 years
cheers to many more i appreciate that
uh and very much appreciate all of the
super chats
that are coming in um
you can also follow my live tweeting at
uh whoa hold on that's not it at uh
deepak
i'm deepakman on twitter and you can
follow me there as well for some of my
additional thoughts
let's listen um to a little bit more of
what's being said
starved and died because they believe
those empty promises
they swallow the communist poison pill
if you have a chance go to the freedom
tower in miami
stop and listen you can still hear the
sounds of those
broken promises
it is the sound of waves in the ocean
carrying families clinging to pieces of
wood
families with children who can't swim
but willing to risk everything to reach
this blessed land
it is the sound of tears hitting the
paper of an application
to become an american citizen
most heard unlike the promises
but soon after they experienced the
reality
look at them listen to them
learn the truth those false
promises spread the wealth
free education free health care
defund the police trust the social
estate
more than your family and your community
they don't sound anybody hear that
whistle that's weird
they sound familiar
fidel castro was asked if he was a guy
sounds like a dog whistle
he said he was a roman catholic he knew
he had
to hide the truth
but the country i was born in is gone
totally destroyed
when i watch the news in seattle chicago
poland and other cities
when i see the history being rewritten
when i hear the promises
i've heard echoes i've heard echoes
of the former life i never wanted to
hear again
i see shadows i thought i had outrun
my parents only wanted one person
to decide my faith me
not somebody member not some government
official
not some bureaucrats in america
i would decide my own future i am so
grateful to america
the place where i was able to build my
american dream
through hard work and determination
president trump knows that the american
story
was written by people just like you and
i
who love our country and take risks
to build a future for our families and
neighbors
i may be a cuban born but i am 100
american
this is the greatest country in the
world
and i said this before if i gave away
everything that i have today
it would not equal 1 of what i was given
when i came to this great country of
ours
the gift of freedom
right now it is up to us to decide our
faith
and to choose freedom
over oppression president trump
he's fighting the forces of anarchy and
communism
no it's not and i know he will continue
to do just that remember there's no
threat of communism in the united states
opponent and the rest of the dc swamp
i have no doubt that will hand the
country over to those
dangerous forces you and i
will decide
and here's what i've decided my decision
is very easy
i choose president trump
because i choose america i choose
freedom
i still hear my dad
there is no other place to go
thank you i made a good lord bless
america
[Music]
the democrats are just going more and
more left many positive about
socialism liking it more than capitalism
oh my god
so that was crazy this is this is insane
um i
i just don't even know what to say guys
this is this is
bonkers this is crazy if this becomes
i mean if we haven't if after all this
trump wins
we just need to rethink the country like
we really we need a serious rethink we
just got to go back to the drawing board
and be like what the hell are we doing i
don't know how else to say it i'm
i'm sort of um my vocabulary is being
stretched to the limit
from the standpoint of being able to
express the level of absurdity that we
have here
um thanks to your majesty
for the twitch prime subscription i do
appreciate that
uh well i just don't even know what to
do
i mean i'll just i'll thank a few people
nathan rarick
is new member number 43 today j.j
o'farrell is number 44.
ruth williams is number 45.
um michael hannah is new member number
46 and now we have nikki haley
nikki haley and it's great to be back at
the republican national convention
i'll start with a little story it's
about an american ambassador to the
united nations
and it's about a speech she gave to this
convention
she called for the re-election of the
republican president she served
and she called out his democratic
opponent
a former vice president from a failed
administration that ambassador said
and i quote democrats always
blame america first the year
was 1984. the president was ronald
reagan
and ambassador gene kirkpatrick's words
are
just as true today
joe biden and the democrats are still
blaming america first they're bringing
donald trump
has always put america first and he has
earned
four more years as president yikes
it was an honor of a lifetime to serve
as the united states ambassador
to the united nations now the u.n is not
for the faint of heart it's a place
where dictators murderers and thieves
denounce america
and then put their hands out and demand
that we
pay their bills well president trump put
an
end to all of that with his leadership
we did what barack obama and joe biden
refused to do we stood up for america
and we stood against our enemies
obama and biden let north korea threaten
america
president trump rejected that weakness
how did those negotiations go sanctions
on north korea
in history obama and biden let iran get
away with murder
and literally sent them a plane full of
cash
president trump did the right thing and
ripped up the iran nuclear deal
obama and biden led the united nations
to denounce
our friend and ally israel
president trump moved our embassy to
jerusalem
and when the u.n tried to condemn us i
was proud to cast
the american veto that was a disaster
this president has a record of
strength and success the former vice
president
has a record of weakness and failure
joe biden is good for iran and isis
great
for communist china and he's a godsend
to everyone who wants america to
apologize
abstain and abandon our values no
mention of russia
donald trump takes a different approach
he's tough on china
and he took on isis and won
and he tells the world what it needs to
hear
at home the president is the clear
choice on jobs in the economy
he's moved america forward while joe
biden has held america back
when joe was vp i was governor of the
great state of south carolina that was
bad
we had a pretty good run manufacturers
of
all kinds flocked to our state from
overseas
creating tens of thousands of american
jobs
people were referring to south carolina
as the beast
of the southeast which i loved what
everything we did
happened in spite of joe biden and his
old boss
we cut taxes they wrote what's weird is
like
now that trump's been president for
almost four years
south carolina is still a disaster on
health care economy
education what's the explanation now
got back and they gave up
a biden harris administration would be
much
much worse last time joe's boss was
obama
this time it would be pelosi sanders
and the squad their vision for america
is socialism and we know that socialism
it's funny the idea that biden cares
what the squad thinks like the critique
from the left is biden doesn't care
about the squad and is in a completely
different place on the political
spectrum
these people are like oh the squad will
control biden massive tax hikes on
working families
joe biden and the socialists left would
be a disaster
for our economy there are almost no
actual
socialists in congress even some who
claim to be
seem confused i mean the idea that
socialism will play
any role in joe biden's presidency is
laughable mimik has set us back
but not for long president trump brought
our economy back before
and he will bring it back again he
brought it back
job growth slowed down when trump took
over from obama
president is right he knows that
political correctness
and cancel culture are dangerous and
just
plain wrong in much of the democratic
party it's now fashionable
to say that america is racist
that is a lie no there are people who
are racist
certainly this is
personal for me i am the proud daughter
of indian immigrants
there it is i came to america and
settled in a small
southern town my father wore a turban
my mother wore a sari i was a brown girl
in a black and white world we faced
discrimination and hardship
but my parents never gave in to
grievance and hate
my mom built a successful business my
dad
taught 30 years at a historically black
college
and the people of south carolina chose
me as their first minority
and first female governor
america is a story that's a work in
progress
now is the time to build on that
progress and make america even freer
fairer and better for everyone that's
why it's so tragic to see
so much of the democratic party turning
a blind eye towards riots
and rage the american people know we can
do better
and of course we value and respect every
black
life the black i do like this
super chat from miss emily oh wait no no
sorry miss emily i love you but that's
not the one i meant
kw nikki haley's english is so simple
and rudimentary she sounds like she's
talking to young children or stupid
people
not altogether incorrect not all not all
together incorrect
emily said thank you for making having
to watch this for work
bearable my pleasure and then w pooh
says
nikki haley registered as a white voter
that's interesting too
our state came face to face with evil
a white supremacist walked into mother
emanuel church
during bible study 12 african americans
pulled up a chair and prayed with him
for an hour then he began to shoot
after that horrific tragedy we didn't
turn against each other
we came together black and white
democrat and republican together we made
the hard choices
needed to heal and removed a divisive
symbol
peacefully and respectfully what
happened then should give us
hope now america isn't perfect
but the principles we hold dear are
perfect
there's one thing i've learned it's that
even
on our worst day we are blessed
to live in america it's time to keep
that blessing alive for the next
generation
this president and this party are
committed to that noble task
we seek a nation that rises together not
falls apart in anarchy and anger
we know that the only way to overcome
america's challenges
is to embrace america's strengths
we are striving to reach a brighter
future where every child goes to a
world-class school
chosen by their parents where every
family lives in a safe community with
good jobs where every entrepreneur has
the freedom to achieve
and inspire where every believer can
worship without fear
and every life is protected
where every girl and boy every woman and
man of every race and religion has the
best
shot at the best life in this election
we must choose the only candidate
who has and who will continue delivering
on that vision
president trump and vice president pence
have my support
and america has our promise we will
build on the progress of our past
and unlock the promise of our future
that future starts when the american
people
reelect president donald trump
thank you good night and may god always
bless
america any ideas why they're not
letting
tulsi speak i know some people in the
chat seem to be
sort of concerned about that um
[Music]
wow uh okay well we're all
we're all reeling from that oh god
here's don jr
good evening america i'm donald trump jr
what's this voice he's
using talk about the great american
story to talk about this country we all
love
this land of promise and opportunity of
heroes
and greatness just a few short months
ago we were seeing the american dream
become a reality
for more of our citizens than ever
before the greatest
prolonged economic expansion in american
history
the lowest unemployment rate in nearly
50 years
the lowest unemployment rates ever for
black americans
hispanic americans women and pretty much
every other demographic group
and then courtesy of the chinese
communist party
the virus struck the president quickly
took action and shut down travel from
china
joe biden and his democrat allies called
my father a racist and a xenophobe for
doing it
does trump even like this kid
correctness ahead of the safety and
security
of the american people fortunately
as the virus began to spread the
president acted quickly and insured
ventilators got to hospitals that needed
them most
he delivered pp and e to our brave
frontline workers
and he rallied the mighty american
private sector to tackle this new
challenge
there's more work to do but there is a
light at the end of the tunnel
job gains are outpacing what the
so-called experts expected
but biden's radical left-wing policies
would stop
our economic recovery cold he's already
talking about shutting the country down
again it's madness democrats claim to be
for workers
but they've spent the entire pandemic
trying to sneak a tax break for
millionaires and democrat states into
the covid relief bill
then they attacked my father for
suspending the payroll tax for middle
class workers
in fact if you think about it john he
didn't really suspend that he deferred
it
they're going to get a big bill next
year working man and woman
he supported the worst trade deals in
the history of the planet
he voted for the nafta nightmare down
the tubes went our auto industry
he pushed for tpp goodbye manufacturing
jobs
beijing biden is so weak on china that
the intelligence community recently
assessed
that the chinese communist party favors
biden
they know he'll weaken us both
economically and on a world stage
we actually need a good relationship
with china given that they're going to
be one of the top
three superpowers for a while
his open border policies would drive
wages down for americans at a time when
low-income workers were getting real
wage increases
for the first time in modern history
he's pledged to repeal the trump tax
cuts
which were the biggest in our country
after eight years of obama and biden
slow growth
trump's policies have been like rocket
fuel to the economy
remember that job growth slowed when
trump took over and the stock market
uh and unemployment and gdp growth all
do better under democrats historically
just facts i don't know if any the facts
matter anymore monster of the swamp
for the past half century he's been
lurking around in there
he sticks his head up every now and then
to run for president
then he disappears and doesn't do much
in between
so if you're looking for hope look to
the man who did what the failed obama
biden administration never could do and
built the greatest economy
our country has ever seen and president
trump will do it again
we will be stronger than ever because
when we put our mind to it
there is no obstacle that america can't
surmount
except there's a difference this time in
the past
both parties believed in the goodness of
america
we agreed on where we wanted to go we
just disagreed on
how to get there this time the other
party is attacking
the very principles on which our nation
was founded
freedom of thought freedom of speech
freedom of religion the rule of law
thomas jefferson famously said i have
sworn upon the altar of god
eternal hostility against every form of
tyranny
over the mind of man our founders
believed
there was nothing more important yeah
he's not screaming the way kimberly
guilfoyle was but it's definitely a
stupider speech
they're trying to cancel all of those
founders they don't seem to understand
this important principle
in order to improve in the future we
must learn from our past
not erase it so we're not going to tear
down monuments and forget the people who
built our great nation
instead we will learn from our past so
we don't repeat any mistakes
and we will work tirelessly to improve
the lives of all americans
joe biden and the radical left are now
coming for our freedom of speech
they want to bully us into submission if
they get their way
it will no longer be the silent majority
it will be
the silenced majority this has to stop
freedom of expression used to be a
liberal value
at least before the radical left took
over
now the republican party is the home of
free speech
the place where anyone from any
background can speak their mind
and may the best ideas win people of
faith are under attack
you're not allowed to go to church but
mass chaos in the streets gets a pass
it's almost like this election is
shaping up to be church
work in school versus rioting looting
and vandalism very much not in the words
of biden and the democrats
peaceful protesting
anarchists have been flooding our
streets and democrat mayors are
ordering the police to stand down small
businesses across
america many of the minority owned are
being torched by mobs
the democrat mayors pretend it's not
happening they actually called it
a summer of love
and that brings me to another important
principle
every american must be free to live
without fear of violence
in your country in your communities and
in
your homes all men and women are created
equal and must be treated equally under
the law
that's why we must put an end to racism
and we must ensure that any police
officer who abuses their powers
is held accountable what happened to
george floyd is a disgrace and if you
know a police officer
you know they agree with that too but we
cannot lose sight of the fact that our
police are american heroes
they deserve our deepest appreciation
because no matter what the democrats say
you and i both know
when we dial 9-1-1 we don't want it
going to voicemail
so defunding the police is not an option
everything starts with safety and
security biden doesn't want to defund
the police just as a reminder for
everybody
a better future for your children
without the peace of mind
that they can study safely in their
classrooms play
safely in their neighborhoods and sleep
safely in their beds
but safety is only the beginning trump's
america is a land of
opportunity a place of promise
i was fortunate enough to grow up in a
family that could afford the best
schools and the finest universities
but a great education cannot be the
exclusive right of the rich and powerful
it must be accessible to all
and that's why my dad is pro school
choice that's why he's called education
access the civil rights issue
not just of our time but of all time
it is unacceptable that being able to go
to charter schools
is much more important as a civil rights
issue than like ending slavery was for
example that makes sense
trump will not stand for it if democrats
really wanted to help minorities and
underserved communities
instead of bowing to big money union
bosses
they'd let parents choose what school is
best for their kids
they'd limit immigration to protect
american workers
they'd support the police who protect
our neighborhoods
they'd learn how to negotiate trade
deals that prioritize america's
interests for a change
they'd end the endless wars and quit
sending our young people to solve
problems in foreign lands
they'd cut taxes for families and
workers
they'd create opportunity zones that
drive investment
into inner cities in other words
if democrats cared for the forgotten men
and women of our country
they'd do exactly what president trump
is doing
america is the greatest country on earth
but my father's entire world view
revolves around the idea
that we can always do even better
imagine the life you want to have one
with a great job
a beautiful home a perfect family you
can have it
imagine the country you want to live in
one with true
equal opportunity where hard work pays
off and justice is served with
compassion and without partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the life
that is the country that is the world
that donald trump and the republican
party are after
and yes you can have it
because unlike joe biden and the radical
left democrats
our party is open to everyone
it starts by rejecting radicals who want
to drag us into the dark
and embracing the man who represents
a bright and beautiful future for all
it starts by re-electing donald j trump
president
of the united states thank you
and god bless america what a delusional
speech everybody
um i mean i'm not even going to comment
on it you guys know that this is just
crazy and it doesn't uh it doesn't it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever
and you know what what can we really say
we can't really say anything about it
it's just
bonkers um a lot of people sending me
super chats and i would love to take
this opportunity to read some of them so
feel free to send me yours if you would
like
mikel browning says no mention of mike
pence at all during this he was
officially renominated earlier though
solange gregory says does anyone have
the number for the betty ford clinic
yeah a lot of people asking that
titan skull says i'm hearing a lot of
pandering platitudes and propaganda
sadly those three ps might still win
trump the election very much so which is
why we have to vote
uh la lakers says day one of the
republican national convention summed up
veritable house of horrors freak show
yes indeed michael oldham says everyone
gets a mistress
under donald trump arisa miacco
says he says every american must be free
to live without fear of violence as a
trans woman i've seen only an increase
in violence and hate under trump
very much so dan alley points out that
this is like george orwell's double
speak i feel like they're reading a wish
list of trump's strengths
and making up anecdotal stories as proof
yes
that is true colin meyers asks
whether don jr was crying his eyes
seemed
almost swollen shut it was weird but i
don't know that he was crying
joey two times says mike pence is like a
leslie nielsen movie reject i loved uh
leslie nielsen
he was fantastic big thank let's go to
twitch guys let's get it going let's get
twitch going let's get it let's re let's
get the hype train out of the station
spencer has subscribed with prime
double zero wet dog has subscribed with
prime
10 az has subscribed with prime but
nobody sent any messages
with those subscriptions
um okay
i guess i don't have too much else to
mention there
i'll do some new members though emily
banks is new member number 47
sean hughes is new member number 48
john sebastian major is number 49
and luke colin kark is number 50.
you know what i like to say when we get
to 50 i say let's go for 75.
um rob paulie is new member number 51 on
my website
who else do i know i'm missing some here
let me go a little further back
um kevin wilkes is number 52.
matzo ball soup is back as new member
number 53.
um edson hopkins matthew steinmetz and
heather crowe
are numbers 54 55 and 56
okay now we're talking guys now we've
got momentum
by the way who are these women and what
are they talking about
and so somebody like aoc alexander
ocasio-cortez this far
left these women come out with these
very oh i'm going to refresh to see if
we can resync the audio and video
because it did seem to get unsynced
voice to these women there has been
an assault on capitalism just generally
and
i think it's very scary to imagine a
biden world where
the progressive wing ideas are starting
to take
front and center stage yeah like you
might pay 39
if you're super rich me there will be
over regulation over taxation
it's very hard to innovate through those
two things
and ultimately what's really sad is the
thought of you know making all of us
dependent on the government
and we are not going to allow that
[Music]
i've seen a lot of moderates a lot of
people
now changing over because of everything
that's been happening
this is a taste of biden's america i
mean this the rioting the crime
freedom is at stake now and this is
going to imagine thinking that
capitalism is in some kind of
crisis in the sense of you know being
weakened it's
crazy to think that's what's going on
that is keeping america great and
president trump has delivered on that
promise
he's truly fighting for the american
people
we're the greatest country in the world
period on our worst day
we're still the greatest country in the
world and in order to preserve that
it's by putting america first
having a thriving economy having
happiness
yep so that's delusional we have a
second hype train of the evening leaving
the station oh actually
let's let's go to senator tim scott good
evening
i'm senator tim scott from the great
state of south carolina
to all of you tuning in and
participating in the political process
god bless you this isn't how i picture
tonight
but our country is experiencing
something none of us envisioned
from a global pandemic to the deaths of
george floyd and brianna taylor
2020 has tested our nation in ways we
haven't seen for decades
but regardless of the challenges
presented to us every four years
americans come together to vote to share
stories of what makes our nation strong
and the lessons we have learned that can
strengthen it for further
generations because while this election
is between donald trump and joe biden
it is not solely about donald trump
and joe biden it's about the promise of
america
it's about you and me our challenges and
heartbreaks
hopes and dreams it's about challenges
and heartbreaks
hopes and dreams it's about how we
respond when tackling critical issues
like police reform
when democrats called our work a token
effort
and walked out of the room during
negotiations
because they wanted the issue more than
they wanted a solution
do we want a society that breeds success
or a culture that cancels everything it
even slightly
disagrees with i know where i stand
because you see
i am living my mother's american dream
what
my parents divorced when i was seven
years old oh and we moved in with my
grandparents into a two-bedroom home
with me my mom and my brother sharing a
room
and one bed my mom worked 16 hours a day
to keep food on the table and a roof
over our heads
she knew that if we could find the
opportunity
bigger things would come i thought i had
to use football to succeed in life
and my focus on academics faded away
my freshman year i failed out i felt
four subjects
spanish english world geography
and even this guy failed four subjects
i'm voting for trump
years in the senate i know i'm not the
only one in congress
who failed civics but even while i was
failing the ninth grade
now you said to me timmy if you would
just shoot for the moon
even if you miss you'll be among the
stars
she never lost faith in me
even when i lost faith in myself
because of her encouragement i went to
summer school and caught up
the next year i met my mentor john moniz
a chick-fil-a operator
john saw something in me that i could
not see in myself
his mentor ran chick-fil-as guys it's
it's beyond parody but creating jobs
would be even better that having an
income could change
my lifestyle but creating a profit
could change my community he planted the
seeds of what would become
opportunity zones this initiative that
the president and i worked together on
is now bringing more than 75 billion
dollars
of private sector investment into
distressed communities
i took those lessons to heart and
started putting the pieces of my life
back together i realized a quality
education is the closest thing to magic
in america
that's why i fight to this day for
school choice
to make sure every child in every
neighborhood
has a quality education i don't care if
it's a public private
charter virtual or a home school when a
parent
has a choice their kid has a better
chance
and the president has fought alongside
me something's wrong with this guy yeah
later in life
i started my own small business that's
why i know
it is critical for us to have a tax code
that encourages growth
we actually saw revenues to the treasury
increase
after we lowered taxes in 2017.
rest assured the democrats do not want
you to know that
after starting my small business and
spending some time in local government
i decided to run for congress in the
district is based in charleston south
carolina
where the civil war started against a
son of our legendary senator
strom thurman you may be asking yourself
hey by the way this super chat here from
ben who says
david you're mocking things you'd loud
for dems i
first of all i was extraordinarily
critical of the democratic national
convention i don't know if you were here
for it
uh and number two just no dude no
overwhelmingly white district the voters
judged me
not on the color of my skin
but on the content of my character
we live in a world that only wants you
to believe
in the bad news racially economically
and culturally polarizing news
the truth is our nation's ark always
bends back towards fairness we are not
fully where we want to be but i thank
god almighty
we are not where we used to be we are
always
that's for sure striving to be better
when we stumble
and we will we pick ourselves back up
and try again we don't give in to cancer
culture
or the radical and factually baseless
belief
that things are worse today than in the
1860s
or the 1960s we have work to do
but i believe in the goodness of america
the promise that all men and all women
are
created equal and if you're watching
tonight
i'm betting you do too over the past
four years
we have made tremendous progress towards
that promise
president trump built the most inclusive
economy
ever seven million jobs created
pre-coveted 19.
and two-thirds of them went to women
africa
remember job growth slowed when obama
left and trump took over
just facts cycle poverty in a generation
opportunity zones we put hard-earned
tax dollars back in people's pockets by
cutting their taxes
especially for single-parent households
like the one i grew up in
cutting single mothers taxes 70
on average president trump supported
these tax cuts
for those single moms and other working
families
and signed these policies into law and
our nation
is better off for it so
i'm going to ask you the american people
he hasn't mentioned his race yet i don't
think which most speakers have i wonder
if he will
but to look back at what they've done
this election is about your future
and it is critical to paint a full
picture of the records
of donald trump and joe biden joe biden
said if a black man didn't vote for him
he wasn't truly black
joe biden said black people are a
monolithic community
it was joe biden who said poor kids
can be just as smart as white kids
and while his words are one thing
his actions take it to a whole new level
in 1994 biden led the charge on a crime
bill that put
millions of black americans behind bars
president trump's criminal justice
reform law fixed
many of the disparities biden created
and made our system more fair and just
for
all americans joe biden also failed our
nations historically black colleges
and universities keeping blame on them
as they fought to ensure
they keep running against the joe biden
of 1993 and 1994.
it's like everybody was more
conservative back then in the democratic
party
things have changed historically high
funding for hbcu
as well as a bill to give them permanent
funding for the first time
ever and now joe biden wants to come for
your pocketbooks
unless of course you're a blue state
millionaire i'm serious
that's one of their solutions for the
pandemic they want to
take more money from your pocket
and give it to manhattan elites and
hollywood moguls
so they get a tax break republicans
however
passed president trump's once in a
generation tax reform bill
that lowered taxes for single moms
working families
and those in need so when it comes to
what
joe biden says he'll do
look at his actions look at his policies
look at what he already did and what he
didn't do
while he's been in washington for 47
years ladies and gentlemen
people don't always see those failures
because they think we're having a policy
debate on two sides of an issue
that is not what is happening our side
is working on policy
while joe biden's radical democrats are
trying to permanently transform
what it means to be an american
make no mistake joe biden
and kamala harris want a cultural
revolution
a fundamentally different america
if we let them yeah they want rich
people to pay 39 instead of 37
and history has taught us that path only
leads to pain
and misery especially for hard working
people
hoping to rise instead we
must focus on the promise of the
american journey
i know that journey well my
grandfather's
99th birthday would have been tomorrow
growing up he had to cross the street if
a white person was coming
he suffered the indignity of being
forced
out of school as a third grader to pick
cotton
and he never learned to read or write
yet he lived long enough to see his
grandson
become the first african-american to be
elected to both
the united states house and the united
states senate
in the history of this country our
family
went from cotton to congress
in one lifetime and that's why i believe
the next american century can be better
than the last
there are millions of families just like
mine
all across this nation full of potential
seeking to live the american dream
and i'm here tonight to tell you that
supporting
the republican ticket gives you the best
chance
of making that dream a reality
god bless you and father please continue
blessing the united states of america
i feel i feel disgusting oh
he was gonna leave with any i guess he
remembered he was told to just stand
there after the speech
um yeah i mean listen not much to say
it's
it's pandering and it's all of it's
lying
uh it's all of the things that we would
expect and that we
saw from the first second that this got
going so there's really not very much to
analyze you know the question is is this
going to activate people to vote
uh or are more of us going to vote right
i mean that's that's fundamentally the
question that we're dealing with
and early voting starts soon and we'll
know the answer
relatively uh relatively soon
um
there's just so much going on uh i don't
know if they are rapping
or if there's one more thing going on
here uh
[Music]
it seems sort of like tim scott was the
keynote there
but uh what were the craziest moments of
the night what do people think i might
want to put out a tweet with the
craziest moments
i think definitely i'm making notes here
guilfoyle
screaming was a top crazy moment
what other specific moments would you
say were the craziest
um
[Music]
trump juniors main squeeze yeah yeah
everybody seems to think it was
it was uh kimberly guilfoyle
but we gotta it has to be more specific
than just listing the people like i'm
talking about specific moments
uh yeah trump's stance
trump unable trump not understanding
what custodian means
like what it mean what someone who's a
custodian does
uh
the guy with the whistling nose yeah i
don't know i don't think i'm gonna do
that
um by the way if it is over and you're
heading out
please make sure to hit the subscribe
button on youtube you'll be notified
when i go live tomorrow
and i just would really appreciate it it
costs nothing and if you're heading out
and you're watching on twitch please
also make sure you follow my uh
my channel on on twitch it's free
and i do appreciate it um
mental plantation wasn't bad
when sean pedrinis took a sip from the
green kool-aid yeah
uh i guess it's over right guys it seems
to be
like it seems that they've wrapped and
now they're just going to this kind of
wide shot i don't know
um
let's see we are going to raid
someone you know what we should do
on on twitch we're going to raid grand
master benjamin feingold
because he's actually become a supporter
of the show
uh i'm just making sure i'm spelling it
correctly gm benjamin feingold yeah
that's gonna be just we'll we'll uh raid
somebody different
each evening and uh no i'm gonna bail
it's been a long day i had a pog champs
match
so no destiny tonight i will talk to
destiny on a different evening so we're
going to
get that raid going momentarily and
that's going to do it
for me we will be back tomorrow thanks
to the super chatters i couldn't even
come close to getting every single one
of them
let's do it
you